LEON NICHOLLS: Do you
want to get your Android
apps on the big screen?
Well, we've made it
easier than ever before.
Hi.
I'm Leon Nicholls from the
Google Developer Relations
Team, and I'm going to tell
you about the Google Cast SDK
Version 3 for Android.
In June 2016, we launched
the new version 3 API
for the Google Cast SDK.
The new Cast SDK
simplifies several parts
of the previous SDK and
addresses the major pain
point identified by content
partners and developers
like you.
The new Cast SDK significantly
reduces the amount
of code needed by
providing UI widgets that
fully comply to the Cast
UX design checklist.
First, here is some terminology
about how casting works.
The Cast sender application
refers to an app
on a mobile device or a laptop.
And a receiver application
case and refer to an HTMI
application running on
Chromecast or other Google Cast
receiver devices.
Let's take a look at the typical
lifecycle of a cast sender app.
When the sender app is
launched, Cast receiver devices
need to be discovered
on the local network.
Once the user selects
a device, a sender app
will connect to their device
and launch the receiver app.
The sender app then
creates a message channel
to the receiver.
The user can also disconnect
from their device at any time.
The new SDK is based on the
design of the Cast companion
library and implements
these new features.
First, the UI widgets that
comply with the Google Cast
design checklist, notification
and lock screen controls,
automatic device
discovery so you
don't have to manage
that in your code,
centralized Cast system
state management,
and a reconnection service
that automatically handles
network issues to
keep your sender app
connected to the receiver.
So even when the
user leaves the room,
goes out of the
range of the network,
the system will be
automatically reconnected
when the user returns.
The Google Cast SDK is still
part of Android's Google Play
services and is shared
across all Cast apps.
The minimum Android SDK level
that the Cast SDK supports
is level 9 or Gingerbread.
In Android Studio, make sure
these necessary libraries
are installed.
Let's take a look at how
to add Cast to your app.
The Cast framework has a
global singleton object,
the Cast Context
which coordinates
all the Cast's interactions.
You must implement
the options provide
interface to supply Cast options
needed to initialize the Cast
Context singleton.
The most important
option is to receive
application ID, which you get
from the Google Cast Developer
Console.
You can get to the
Cast Context instance
by using the static
getSharedInstance method.
If you've used to v2 SDK
before, you must be wondering,
where is the Google API client?
That's not needed
anymore to use Cast.
Everything is done for
you by the v3 framework.
For your app's UI, the first
step in supporting Cast
is to add the Cast button.
The SDK provides a
Cast button widget
that automatically manages
its visibility and state
and provides all the
necessary dialogs for users
to select and
disconnect devices.
The Cast button is implemented
by the media route button
from media route of
version 7 support library.
Like any action
icon that you can
add to your activity-- using
an action bar or a tool bar--
you first need to add
the corresponding item
to your main you.
Once you've done that, override
the onCreateOptionsMenu method
of each of your activities by
using the Cast button factory
to wire up the media add
button to the Cast framework.
When the user selects a Cast
device using the Cast button
menu, the new Cast session
is started automatically
by the framework.
All the user
interactions, including
backing out of this menu,
are handled by the widget.
The list of devices
is [INAUDIBLE]
based on the app ID
configuration in the Google
Cast Developer Console.
For the Cast framework,
a Cast session
encapsulates the
connection to a device,
managing the
receiver application,
and initializing a media
control channel for media apps.
Cast sessions are managed by
the system manager which can be
accessed via the Cast context.
The system manager
listener callbacks
can be used to monitor session
and main status, creation,
suspension, resumption, and
termination of the session.
To play media on the
receiver, the send app
has to provide media
metadata of the media stream.
Here you can see how to set the
media type, title, and images
using the media metadata class.
Here you can see how to
set the media URL, stream
type, and other metadata using
the MediaInfo Builder class.
The remote media
client class is then
used to load that media
stream on the receiver.
The send app then
invokes commands
such as play and pause using the
remote media client instance.
The send app can use the system
manager listener callbacks
to track the session
state and determine
when to enable and disable
the local media player.
Playing media on the
receiver is now a breeze.
The Cast SDK provides a widget
called the Mini Controller that
appears when the user navigates
away from the current content
page to another part of the app.
The Mimi Controller
provides instant access
and is a visible reminder
for the current Cast session.
The Cast SDK provides a custom
view Mini Controller fragment
which can be added
to the app layout
file of the activities
in which you want
to show the Mini Controller.
This is so much
easier than the v2 SDK
where you had to create the
Mini Controller yourself.
The Google Cast design
checklist requires a send app
to implement media controls
from a notification
and the lock screen.
This is allows
users to always be
in control of the media session
with convenient playback
control buttons.
The Cast SDK provides a
media notification service
to help the sender build these
controls for the notification
and lock screen.
The media notification service
will run in the background
when the sender is Casting
and will show a notification
with an image
thumbnail, metadata
about the current Casting item,
a Play/Pause button, and a Stop
button.
Here you can see how the
notification and lock screen
controls can be enabled
with the Cast options
when initializing
the Cast context.
Notifications are then
managed for your app
by the Cast framework.
It's that easy.
The Google Cast design
checklist requires the sender
to provide an
expanded controller
for the media being Cast.
The expanded controller is kind
of like a full-screen version
of the Mini Controller.
The Cast SDK provides a widget
for the expanded controller
called the Expanded
Control Activity,
which is implemented
as an abstract class.
To add an expanded
controller, subclass
ExpandedControllerActivity
and add a Cast button.
After you've done that, edit
the Cast options provider
and change the notification
options and Cast media options
to set the target activity to
your subclass of the Expanded
Control Activity.
The expanded controller widget
will save you a lot of code
if you've used
the v2 SDK before.
Now that you've integrated
Cast with your app,
how do you tell
your users about it?
Well, the Cast SDK
provides a custom view
called Introductory Overlay.
That can be used to highlight
the Cast button when it's first
shown to the user.
This code shows you how to
use the IntroductoryOverlay
Builder to show the
overlay in your activities.
That's everything you need to
Cast enable your sender app.
You can get a lot more details
about the Google Cast SDK
at developers.google.com/cast.
We've also open sourced
several sample Cast apps
that you can use as a reference.
If you have any
developer questions,
post those on Stack Overflow.
Join our Google Cast developers
community on Google+ to keep up
to date with the
new SDK features.
Happy Casting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]